hello everyone and welcome
today I am playing Pokemon Violet I
chose Violet because I think the
other legendary looks really silly I've
been really excited about this game and
so it's a bummer that I've heard that
there are technical issues I can still
often have fun even when a game has
technical issues
um depending on the variants I loved all
Bethesda games all right I can still
have a good time
so I'm hoping that they're not like game
breakingly bad and then I'll still have
fun
um I'm willing to tolerate it as much as
that seems notes considering
Pokemon is the biggest franchise ever
and they keep doing this but I still
have a good time so
uh
uh choose a look for yourself who do I
want to be
I mean this is probably the closest to
me realistically
[Music]
all right let me get rid of this dog cam
now that he's disappeared
what is your name
as always in every game ever it is
okay uh
Owen
I should split my camera give me a
second I'm currently playing with my OBS
screen because I just didn't it didn't
occur to me to split the
split my screen public give me a sec let
me do that
all right
let's do it
the music got louder
you can't change your language or name
after starting the game okay
[Music]
that's I mean that's pretty much how I
look right now but I'm so used to this
side no not that one not that kind of
side Club
pompadour huh
[Music]
tussled Croc
I think we've probably gotta go with the
the long and
well no how did I get the hair color
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
oh I clipped over uh-huh okay it's got
to be long and straight
[Music]
and I guess I'm not making chaos but
whatever
um and then platinum blonde probably
well there it is
[Music]
silver
nope damn it
[Music]
that's it
going straight
confirm yes
[Music]
all right now I want to change my name
though so I'm gonna go back and I'm just
gonna be Alana
Alana
that's me
okay
beautiful
[Music]
oh do I look weirdly colored for all of
you probably not no it's just my capture
on my screen sorry my HDR
I think so uh language English
yeah let's do it cool
thank you
I'm really excited about this game
I hope to lose the entirety of
Thanksgiving week to playing this
leading the way into the future while
valuing our individuality
[Music]
it's time for you two to dive into the
world of Pokemon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
director clavel head of I don't know if
it's Yuva or UV I don't remember from
the presentations
paldea is a sprawling region bursting
with Lush nature and magnificent
landscapes
it is also of course home to the
mysterious creatures known as Pokemon
I'm doing my best Nintendo Direct
Pokemon reader voice where they're so
enthusiastic
they reside here in great numbers in
fact
Nintendo go high come on
I'm ready to do it whenever you want
[Music]
oh
Pokemon can be found living all over in
the seas in the skies Even in our cities
and towns
we humans coexist with Pokemon as we
both help one another to live and thrive
she got cool hair look at these people
with that cool hair all right
Yuba Academy is here to help you learn
even more about these precious partners
within our Halls people from all regions
gather to study together
touching my face because I have to smile
so much
and as Pokemon trainers they have the
Pokemon to do battle they have their
Pokemon do battle growing alongside that
this sentence is very sadistic but I
read it in the happiest voice ever okay
hang on
and as Pokemon trainers they have their
Pokemon do battle
growing alongside them
while our robust curriculum of
coursework helps our students draw forth
their fullest potential
oh that was the end of the sentence my
bad sorry can I retake that line yeah
just give me another take of that one
cool yeah thanks run it back
we the faculty and staff at Yuba Academy
can't wait to welcome you with open arms
and my face hurts
makes sense
I just call it deny being super excited
about this game and the multiplayer
you've come so far man
from the days in red and blue to this
weird motorbike
we've come so far
[Music]
though I shot there made it look like he
was like damn
damn Lighthouse you looking thick
tonight
you mind if I slide up on you Mommy
and he did
oh it's the Elvis Birds
[Music]
it's beautiful it's it's beautiful it's
beautiful
yeah it's me
cool shoes dork
who's already had a frame rate drop and
it's cinematic that is the exact switch
that I have though
I love my controller it's a bit more
slightly more comfortable
get up
[Music]
those are
some frames
um it's okay
okay it's fine no it's fine it's fine
it's gonna be fine
this is
rich kids okay
this is Rich Kids is what this is
there's
my bedroom could not have looked more
different to this when I was child
this is the least relatable thing I've
ever seen this much space
your house look like this
you got the like I forget what they call
it what the bedroom that's at the top of
the staircase
no not me son
not I
foreign
[Music]
nice um monstera I believe that is good
choice good plant
[Music]
what'd you call me
did you just call me a lesbian
dude this house is so nice
come on now what
okay
Who you calling muncha
[Music]
very cute all right
this is very pretty
it's nuts man yeah when I was a kid I
would have blown my mind to see Pokemon
come this far also let me know if I
should make my webcam smaller it's
pretty big uh right now
um
but I'm having all these
capture errors at the moment
oh already in your uniform and
everything oh my God she's hot
she's she super hot
well it is your first day at your new
school after all
I'm so excited for you okay I was taking
that with a negative tone
I was taking that with with uh oh I'm
sad maybe it's a Twist hang on I'm so
excited for you it was an anime twist
the top 10 anime betrayals still you
might want to cool your engines before
you go racing out the door
School contacted me and said that you're
supposed to wait here a little while
longer
why
their words not mine see she looks sad
that's why I played it sad you
understand
apparently there's something very
important for your first day that still
hasn't arrived
[Music]
is it [ __ ] maybe that's the very
thing we're waiting for Alana get the
door won't you would you
all right
which we got so many doors in this house
dude I
the wealth on display which door
there are too many okay
[Music]
oh it's an academy daddy yes
on behalf of the Academy I must
apologize for the late arrival of your
enrollment document ah and also for my
delay in introducing myself
[ __ ] YouTube
I am the director of HIPAA Academy you
may call me Mr clavel that's how you
would sound right
the director and you came in person to
help my daughter with her first day
where I am responsible for the entire
Academy including any failures on its
part
so here at last of the enrollment
documents that should have already been
delivered to you
really starting with some drama here
she's so hot dude what the [ __ ] come on
now
goodness you really didn't have since
you've come all this way can I at least
offer you a cup of tea
oh no need to trouble yourself
[Music]
a lot I've got a thing or two to discuss
with the director here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
why don't you head back up to your room
and finish getting ready for school
you'll need your bag and your hat as
well
it was actually a part of the
uniform in Australia that we had to wear
hats you would get detention if you did
not wear your wide brim hat
uh now Mr clavel he simply must join me
for a couple of this way oh now I want a
cup of tea how can I refuse such a kind
of I don't know you're probably busy
all right I guess I'll just let another
old dude Bond my mom while I'm upstairs
it's fine
dad's coming back any minute
[Music]
cool
I am yeah
[Music]
let's do it
[Music]
she do look cute
though this there's no school that I
went to that would have let us wear
shorts that show either
to fix my webcam
you can press the x button to open the
main menu strange but okay select the
save option from this menu to save all
the progress you've made on your
adventure so far when you open up your
bag you'll find some key items inside
including your adventure Guide check out
whenever you want to review handy tips
like these that you receive along your
adventure
she does look cute okay I could cosplay
this in a heartbeat but it would just be
my own character so what's the value
look at it though all right
thank you Micah has it
[Music]
you're already done
oh just look at you all ready for your
first big day
[Music]
yes the uniform of our storage Academy
suits you quite well indeed
oh gracious how are you careless of me I
had entirely forgotten that I have
something else for you Mr Lara the most
important thing
but your living room is hardly the place
for it would you care to follow me
outside out fire type
do you have any fire type I wonder what
this important thing might be let's
follow the director out and see shall we
sometimes I can't talk
hang on I didn't uh damn it's gonna
scope out the other part of the house
there's a lot of doors that I didn't
investigate
I'm really liking the settings so far
again unfortunate
what a pleasant opening though you know
right then dear Pokemon time to come out
from your Pokeballs
I'm such a big fan of Elvis duck
I'm not gonna deny that
we provide each student entering the
academy Pokemon off their own I'll ask
you to choose which among these three
you'd like to have as your partner
brigadito the grass cat Pokemon
cute
the fire Croc Pokemon I mean he looks
like an absolute dumbass but I have to I
do pick fire type every time which
I don't know supposedly you're not
supposed to but that's I'm loyal okay
look at this absolute [ __ ] I love him
I would die for him
you have my life
and quaxley the duckling Pokemon no
look I love you also but
you need to calm down I just think the
energy is wrong
exactly pomp is what you would say
they're all very good company why they
usually refuse to even leave my side
but he walked over first so obviously I
got to pick it
so it turns out they're more interested
in you miss Alana than familiar old to
me
oh thanks for letting me know we are
darbia you can change the clothes by
pressing left to deeper
why did that come up as a first time
chat
strange
foreign
if that is can you text me because
otherwise I feel like that's probably a
fake account using your name
because it said it was your first
message submitted so
I'm not convinced
um okay
I do wish I could stay and see which one
you'll choose but it must be off to my
next home visit how do you have time all
these moms
I'll be at the house just over there
take your time with your decision and
come find me once your mind is made up
now if you'd excuse me until we next
week
all right boss man
what a manly fellow oh no that's she's
not English hang on what a mannerly
fellow that director of yours is
she's wet these three are all lovely but
you need to choose just one right not an
easy task
why not take this opportunity to walk
about with these little ones and get to
know them
I'm sure they have lots to teach you
oh uh but before you go I got you a
little something to celebrate your big
day take it with you if you're going out
on your own
[Music]
the Rotom phone all right
latest model of smartphone got it a
Pokemon called rotumblips within it ugh
and it can be used to run all sorts of
Handy apps that's [ __ ] up that's
[ __ ] up
oh no according to the instructions you
can check the map app by pressing the Y
button
the map app it'll help keep you from
getting lost so take good care of your
new Gadget okay now off you go have fun
thanks Mom love you
I'm gonna take this fire type
[ __ ] ass Dopey looking look at him
dear God it's it's you oh my God okay
so
I really like
right now like the setting the music's
really nice I'm not loving how the
camera is automatically changing
but God why
does
Pokemon make everything so [ __ ] sharp
it's like the resolutions just I feel
like they're always like this
this is not not pretty
um
technically yeah I really don't like
that the camera is auto tracking me as
well but I can just keep my hand on
there I guess it's fine
[Music]
pick it up how
just an A okay oh okay I thought that
was going to be Pokeball this is really
pretty though like the the design of
this world is really nice are they all
following me that's also very cute
very cute
um again sorry if that is you please
text me
the internet knows the name of my
childhood dog
you just have to be sure
or send a Facebook message or whatever
[Music]
all right Pokeball a device for catching
wild Pokemon I don't remember uh hang on
there's there's also I used to be able
to do the voice of the Pokedex guy
a Pokeball
a device for catching a wild Pokemon
that's that's close enough
um the size of this Garden
yeah these people are loaded and this is
a really beautiful setting like it is it
is beautiful it's a shame that uh it's
already a bit scratchy
okay confirmed uh it is my sister if you
wanna you wanna mod her you can
what are you freaking out about I'm
allergic to cats stay away heathen
[Music]
yeah it's conflicting The Vibes of this
are wonderful but um I also feel a
little bit like I want to vomit
it's kind of worse than I expected
[Music]
I started running hello
friend
this is Cabo Poco it's not much just a
little pinch of community but it's home
cool
you can't oh of course yeah I have to
monitor hang on
uh
mod there you go
yeah it should have worked
beautiful yeah it is weird it says
you've never said uh sent a message
before
the power of science
sizing
together up to four of you at a time
that doesn't seem like science that
seems like something that applies in the
real world my guy
[Music]
that's also a bit rough
it's uh the item pickup is not as smooth
as I might have hoped
[Music]
this loser
okay I take it back he's Chad I'm just
jealous
where are they gonna put my little
crocodile where's he gonna go there's no
fire here
he's just with an orange
[Laughter]
they're like I don't know he's eyes with
a fruit
yeah yeah
it has to be him how can anyone pick
anyone other than him
[Music]
not quite Miss Alana has yet to make her
choice you see that's true
I do wonder which of them she would
choose as her first Pokemon
it's
come on all right there was never any
doubt who I was gonna choose was my
first Pokemon come on look at him look
at his he's a Labrador
what else was I supposed to pick
why not we haven't met having
I must say I wasn't expecting to see you
okay quite so soon
what else did you think I was going to
be doing
hang on director is that who I think it
is
yes this is our Academy's new student
Miss Alana she will be attending as of
today I think I've decided he's evil
so you're that kid who moved up in the
road
in up the road
I've been dying to find out more about
you
I made us sound the same as the mom
she should maybe she can be Australian
I'm pneumonia normally I live in the
school dorms but home is here what are
you saying you neighbor want to be
friends
yeah
love that enthusiasm we're gonna get
along just fine
Miss nimona is president of our student
council and a Champion Bank trainer in
her own right
I absolutely love Pokemon battling in
fact we should better right now mate you
and me
easy now you two will be in the same
class so you have plenty of time to
battle later
and get to know one another better of
course I ship us
we're going to be neighbors and
classmates nice uh we'll be able to
battle what we want
again
as I age the principles of Pokemon
just get a little
um more concerning a second one
on that note Miss Solana
it's look at this look at him look at
him it's him obviously look
have you decided which of these Pokemon
you would like to be your first partner
yes
this stupid [ __ ] look at him
oh my God hello hello hello sweet boy
come into my life
foreign
yes
that's way Coco
a fire type Pokemon
the burning hot Sparks it scattles with
fry any and all plants in a Flash
would you like to go with a good fire
type Pokemon for Coco here am I
pronouncing it right by Coco
he is fire Totodile you're actually
absolutely not wrong yeah
you're 100 right
um but yes I would thank you
oh my god dude I love you a lot
you chose way Coco would you like to
give way Coco a nickname no I find it
too confusing
unless I can swear hang off hang on
let me let's just give it a shot all
right can I call him [ __ ]
if not it's way Coco
[Laughter]
foreign
devastating devastating no that would be
the only name that would suffice because
that's what I'm going to call him the
whole game until he evolves into his
ugly teenage years
okay
he looks heavy he looks pretty heavy
[Music]
I'm just happy to be here man I'm just
happy to be here you know
I'm just happy this is happening for me
right now
like Coco seems to have taken quite a
liking to you Miss Alana
this is your first Pokemon yes please
raise it to love and care
and of course be sure to keep it tucked
safely inside a Pokeball
seems unnecessary when they were just
roaming around free perfectly fine but
okay Alana I can't believe you actually
chose play Coco
I mean like a way to make the perfect
choice for you you need to make such a
good combo is this there like
it's she's supposed to be my rival but
they're changing the
change in the pace you know
oh Tim Gettys is playing Pokemon pilot
can I choose one of these Pokemon to
direct level
oh but did you not receive a Pokemon
When you entered the Academy Mr Moon
not back then no I had other Pokemon I
was focused on raising at the time
but now I want to raise a new Pokemon
alongside Alana while she raises her own
new partner
indeed a rather sprinted idea if you
wish to raise one of these Pokemon an
equal footing with Miss Alana here I
shall be more than happy to allow it
could just said yes yes crikey
that's sick
all right since Alana chose boy Coco
I'll go for this little one
nice to meet you sprigatido welcome to
the team
oh
foreign
I think she chose the cap because she
knows I'm allergic
all right then
now that we've chosen our Pokemon we
have to battle
I'll be waiting for you down at the
Beach come join me when you're ready
as you may have noticed Miss pneumonia
is a tad overly fond of Pokemon battling
but I do hope you'll join it for a
battle it will help you get to know your
own Pokemon as well
all right
battle nimono oh why check
okay the map looks pretty good the handy
roads on phone is a popular item used
throughout the Palladium pal day I keep
saying paladea paldaya region adding
apps to it gives it gives a trainer
access to a variety of useful functions
using the map you can find useful
information about the pal data region if
you move the map cursor over your own
icon and then move the right stick from
side to side you'll rotate your own view
along with the map wait what
if you move the map cursor
just it's just right stick
not sure
we'll figure it out you can leave you
use a left stick to move the magnifying
glass around the map and find locations
select a location by pressing the a
button we set it as your next
destination the flying taxi service can
take you to some places this is
definitely the most rich man's Pokemon
of all time
we've come a long way
this is very rich man's Pokemon
oh wait
I'm sorry turns out you have two
accounts is that what's happening
this makes a lot more sense this one has
300 messages
weird
I have two twin sisters with the same
name and they're both mods just one and
two accounts I think strange you
probably made a um that's funny sorry
you probably made an account with your
usual username and then forgot that you
did it and so then at some point made
another one
that happens
um okay flight taxi service can take you
some places you visited before places
that you can fly to are indicated with a
feather Mark try taking flight
Okay so
it's um it says if I move the map cursor
then I will move with it
I'm not seeing myself move but okay
well this is where I want to go
how do I move the map cursor
lock the map rotation so it always
points not that's why it gets confusing
you could do with r31 on the map screen
well uh is it currently pointing off
hang on yes so that's North
I don't uh what did it mean about making
sure I faced the same way as the map
I'm unclear
we'll figure it out oh
it made it do that
well it's gonna be fine anyway because
that minimap's so big well why are there
Pokemon on the map
yeah fine
fine
stupid Australian so needy always going
to beaches I can't wait to go home for
Christmas
I'm very excited I'm talking to my mom
like all the time being like I'm gonna
go to the beach every day [ __ ] it's
gonna be great
the minute it turns to Winter over here
I'm like um because Australia is summer
so I get to dodge winter entirely
okay
this is just again very pretty this is
the prettiest hideous game I've ever
played
like
I'm so impressed by this setting
and thus the art style the art Direction
thus far I'm super impressed by
um
technically
are those really supposed to be palm
trees like it just looks so bad so
ah
Pokemon is the highest grossing
franchise of all time
we know you can do better we know
it's um
a huge bummer
and this it's like it's so at odds with
itself it does look like OG PlayStation
like I don't disagree
it would be beautiful at a proper
resolution it's so weird
such a shame
foreign
can be a Pokemon trainer as long as they
have Pokemon by their side
and it's our duty as trainers to help
our Pokemon grow stronger through battle
so you ready to battle me Alana
Perfecto I'm so excited for this battle
I think I'll use
Miss
wait he's why is he here
I trust you remember that Miss Alana is
wholly inexperienced in Pokemon battle
whoops good cool director I was about to
send out one of my usual Partners right
off the bat I guess I'll take this
chance to try out my new buddy instead
that would have been really messed up
that would have been real bad
come on Alana let's have us a fruitful
battle
[Music]
you are challenged by Pokemon Trina and
pneumona oh hang on that was the overly
enthusiastic voice okay damn it it's too
fast go play Coco
I know this is your first Pokemon battle
so let's just have some fun
battle I'm gonna go straight for Ember
obviously
[Music]
it's all right I can take a scratch
it's super effective
[Music]
yeah thanks
[Music]
I'm just gonna do it again
it's all right I can take that too
[Music]
I like the the camera work there like
that aspect of the fight is is nice
[Music]
wow not bad neighbor
she gave me 300 for that
look at you winning your first battle
ever
you've got even more potential than I
thought
you're going to be a strong trainer for
sure
but now I want to try a different
strategy let's go again just one more
battle I didn't get to rest first
Miss Alana and her Flair Coco are surely
weary already from that last one thank
you
oh sorry I got kind of caught up in all
the excitement
I'm really sorry Alana send me to your
play Coco too
don't worry about it
all right thanks Alana
look at her eyes very nice
you two seem to be becoming fast friends
they'll be only just knit
can I count on you to take your new
schoolmates you're under your witness
the murder she seems psycho dude I don't
know about that she's she seems kind of
crazy
I'm sure she can learn a great deal from
a champion like trainer such as herself
you bet sir
oh that reminds me since you're new to
training Pokemon there's an app you
definitely need
you have a smartphone right what are you
poor let me see it for a second do not
hand your phone to strangers don't don't
do that that's a bad idea we don't want
to do any of that
the Pokedex app was the Pokedex app was
added to your Rotom phone
[Music]
the Pokedex will automatically register
any Pokemon you catch it's a must-have
for Pokemon trains it's a super handy
app our homeroom teacher Mr Jacques
actually made it himself
cool
back in my day we use ordinary paper and
handwritten notes to compile our
pokedexes
it's quite the age we live in now all
right Boomer
oh filling out a pokedex by hand I can't
even imagine how much work that would
take
yeah I suppose you can't that was a sick
phone
that was that was I just got absolutely
roasted
yet no matter how much the times change
the Wonder of meeting new Pokemon never
does
it's truly a Timeless pleasure I agree
with that but like for meeting different
dogs
all people's dogs
I'm a big fan of that and the more
Pokemon that you encounter the more
you'll find yourself growing and
changing
[Music]
I hope you would both work hard towards
the goal of completing your own
pokedexes
another thing about the minimap not
relevant yet but it is a bit confusing
the Pokemon you see and it may appear in
the general era you're at at the time
it's not pointing specific locations
and it can show you Pokemon that haven't
actually spawned oh okay so it's like
this is an area where you may be able to
find this thing that's cool I think
that's a good idea
um yep
now miss nomodo I do still have a few
matters to discuss with your parents
he's gonna [ __ ] her mom too
sorry about that can I depend on you to
see Mr Solana to the academy you'll be
doing quite the favor
I had to go lay some pipe on your mum of
course leave it to me
then I leave her in your capable hands
her shoes are awake all over the night
[Music]
all right everyone it's time you and I
we're on our way my dad calls me little
one so it hits different
the nickname that my dad gave me
able to make a little more time to work
on my Pokedex along with all my battling
all right speaking of pokedex's Alana
you probably never caught a wild Pokemon
right I'll show you the ropes before I
damn it and press AC boss
look at these deck chairs dude what a
cool place to hang out um press the
minus button to open the Pokemon app on
your Rotom phone in a Flash cool you can
also navigate to your Pokedex by
pressing the x button from the map app
right now it has nothing in it I assume
the Pokedex app battle or catch Pokemon
to compile volumes in your pokedex app
with fancier covers Pokemon you've
caught
oh that's cool
open up your Pokedex to view all the
volumes you've collected on a digital
shelf and check out what rewards you can
earn by pressing the x button
button when looking at a Pokemon you
registered in your Pokedex and you can
check that Pokemon's Habitat to learn
more about where they can be found wow
damn sweet I had to talk to friends
about this back in the day
how cool
um okay now thank you for joining Oscar
I appreciate that
is my dad Thanos
no he just calls me little one because
I'm the youngest sister
thank you for asking Ava my dog's doing
good he's currently getting Physical
Therapy which is brought some challenges
because he's not allowed to exercise as
much which he does not like
how is my headache thing I have not had
a migraine since I had surgery which is
awesome
hopefully it stays that way it seems
like it will at this point I'm doing
good
um okay
I like this
look at him stupid idiot can you change
the pictures I wonder
and then what happens if you I have to
keep looking at the controller because
I'm swapping between so many consoles at
the moment
that I'm gonna have to be like x uh I'll
get used to it pretty fast at these days
though
so X does what
take nothing from you
oh okay
profile
that's me
thank you a purpose appreciate you
oh is the game playable I've had mixed
things
um so we're only about half an hour in
right now
and
all right so I have I really can't say
right now my oh yeah sorry the mini map
is on the bottom uh right I'm covering
it yeah
um
right now I would say it's playable but
I've done very little
but it it's really unfortunately
outdated like
y'all didn't even try with the textures
you know
um and it's a shame because I do think
it's really beautiful I think this is
a very pleasant place to be like I'm I'm
liking this environment a whole lot it's
I'm happy like I'm happy to be playing
it
but it just
some of the frame rate drops have
already like that like
had an effect on my stomach which is
unfortunate
do you know spray tight medicine for
treating poisoning
oh that's cool you can walk up and down
well at least down ledges
whoa
all right look at us go a new Pokemon
okay
all right
no we can jump down ledges
you flooded with my mom
God damn it Mom oh Alana
I hear that pneumonia here will be
taking you to school
that's right ma'am leave it to me
so you've already managed to make a
friend
and I read all about the wonderful
teachers you'll have looking after you
at the school plus so many handy
facilities you can use as much as you
like
add in your new friend nimona and it
sounds like your school life is shaping
up to be fantastic I'm not even mad yet
[ __ ] pipe down
now you'll be staying in the school dorm
so I want you to promise me you'll eat
proper meals dude I when I was in
college in San Jose
I literally I ate so badly because like
you're studying
and it's the dorm experience that we
don't have that in Australia but it is
in the US and I experience the US
version
um
I like would go to the food Hall
and get like a takeaway coffee cup and
put a bunch of spinach and like eggs in
it
just to have something to eat on the go
I was eating from coffee cups that just
had
food in them as much as possible my God
it was not good that said sjsu which is
why I studied um for that period of time
has this bagel shop
that's just around the corner
that I think about a lot The sjsu Bagel
Shop
my God
fantastic
um
okay
here's a bit of spending money to start
off with I also packed a lunch for your
first day
sandwich from Mom she's just in a happy
she's just in a good mood because she
just got [ __ ] down all right
what's wrong
what's wrong I'm so sorry
oh now I have a sandwich recipe a dish
made by sandwiching vegetables meat or
other ingredients between two pieces of
bread it makes a fantastic meal when out
on a picnic
oh and maybe we'd better take these too
five potions
you put the potions in your bag's
medicine pocket
use them on that precious little partner
of yours should he get hurt in battle
should it I know every day in your new
life is going to be full of exciting
experiences far from home
just trying to savor them all the good
times and the hard times too
but if you ever want to come back home
you know your bed is always ready for
you
oh all right then you two would better
be off I suppose take care on the way to
school
all right let's do it
[Music]
your mom's so nice Alana
oh but I was going to teach you how to
catch a wild Pokemon come on battles oh
wait should I be making her she's not
Australian
she's
Latina
this way
so okay that was a bit odd bit of a
freeze there for some reason
[Music]
[ __ ] path
all right this here is Pokemon
it's just sort of a park
a bit of a park
it's the part that leads to Adventure
for you and me out here things are
different than in town you're going to
see wild Pokemon out and about
they'll be on the path and in the grass
as such
look at his little tail
oh that's right you can see Pokemon now
get too close to one and you'll have to
battle but you've got free Coco for that
right and if you want to try catch a
Pokemon you gotta use
a good old Pokeball
I've got tons have a few
thank you kind lady
do I know how to use the bag yet I want
to use the potion soup for it quicker
time for some learning by doing try
battling this lechonk Alana I love for
chunk that the fact that his name's Le
chunk I would die for him
show me [ __ ] but protective
I am playing technically on the switch
Pro O2 byz technically
um though I guess it doesn't actually
have better resolution
okay you can try to catch a wild Pokemon
you are battling by pressing the x
button and a thrilling Pokeball when
you're having a hard time catching a
Pokemon try to deal damage to you before
throwing another Pokeball that should
give you a better chance of success I
don't really want Villa chalk
maybe I should just for fun
foreign
this all seems to be running pretty well
I really like the animation
yeah I'm gonna kill him I don't want it
I don't want the chunk
I don't need you in my life
I guess I know that there's a world
where you're supposed to just catch
every Pokemon and let some of them go or
whatever but
it ain't me
you think you're gonna wait for the bugs
to get fixed there is no a guarantee
that that will happen unfortunately with
the way that game freak works
nice defeating Pokemon in battle will
help way Coco grow and get stronger next
time try doing a Pokeball with Pokemon's
right on the tip of being defeated
you'll have a decent chance of catching
it then again as I get older it seems
more [ __ ] up anyway I have some more
pokeballs just in case not every catch
works out
[Music]
you obtained 10 pokeballs you put the
pokeballs in your bags Pokeball pocket
weaken the Pokemon then throw the
Pokeball remember that and you'll be
fine
now go battle those wild Pokemon and
catch some of them
Let's uh excuse me let's meet back up at
that Lighthouse over there and you can
see how School comes up can you
that's pretty sick the Pokemon you see
wandering around in tokoros caves and
elsewhere are wild Pokemon when you run
into a wild Pokemon a Pokemon battle
we'll begin you can also start about it
by looking toward a wild Pokemon
throwing one of your pokeballs at it
using the ZR button try this tactic out
to battle a Pokemon that are up and the
trees are flying in the sky wow
I appreciate the Innovation I'm into it
all right oh frames
maybe we just fight another chunk I
guess
[Music]
how is my Coco I guess because that was
just tutorial
like I still have all my
HP and AP
foreign
[Music]
but why
hello
really just uh
screwing up the chunks right now that's
my whole ammo
I do really appreciate that you can see
the attacks actually land that's
it is good
[Music]
[Music]
oh hello Rahul welcome
way Coco learned round is that what that
just said
how dare you mock play Coco like that
the auto Hill feature will automatically
select items from your bag and use them
oh
do you use Auto heal highlight the
Pokemon you want to heal from the main
menu
do I want to do this
no right because then I feel like you
would just waste too many of them
I don't think I I can make him the lead
Pokemon oh I just pressed X hang on it's
supposed to be y mean why
that's why
I don't want to Auto heal him
I just want to give him a potion and he
doesn't need one he doesn't need one no
he's fine shut up
shut up I don't care shut up
thank you
for somebody else oh hello a familiar
friend
[Music]
Rahul I actually assumed that you were
playing dark tide right now because I
saw it my steam popped up and said that
Bruce was and I was like well then
surely Bravo is too
surely that's why Bruce is playing
did I get both questions so I can trade
with myself not anymore I only did that
in high school okay I'm cool now
I literally bought two DS's
um when I was in high school so that I
could trade Pokemon
uh to myself
um
but so that I would have constant trade
XP boosts
so
there's that
oh I didn't even mean to fight you dude
but I guess why not
[Music]
thank you
should I use round
that actually looked pretty sick
and actually look pretty cool
[Music]
right now that you have too many potions
you can avoid using if you want but
later you'll have so many won't matter
if you waste a couple
really I feel like that's not my
experience with other Pokemon games well
I guess it is with just base poke
potions but not with like super potions
um
but if this game is balanced a little
bit differently
that's interesting
you should sorry you should play Pokemon
[Music]
if you play Scarlet I can trade with you
because I'm playing violet
when I come home
[Music]
to round Chilla get out of here
all right
okay let's try this I wanted to and
that's
I want to catch it I just want to fight
it
please don't catch the spider I don't
want anything to do with it all right
that's that's cool too that's a cool
mechanic
just some some
very cool
I use the word cool a lot
but there are some very cool
mechanics here what's this
oh he ran away oh
that's very sad who are you hello kick
your butt too I'll kick all your butts
[Music]
well like cinderbug
ERT
oh yes when I say home I'm referring to
Australia
and hopefully I never stopped doing that
that said I think when I'm in Australia
I refer to home as the US so it depends
where I am another one
home is wherever I am not
[Music]
okay
it is a verb
little cutie all right
come on everybody I imagine that I have
a pretty good special attack based on
how well it's healing
foreign
[Music]
oh I guess I realize I'm also covering
the
probably move the webcam but Pokemon's
also pretty intuitive like I figure you
know what I'm doing right
let's move it up here
um
[Music]
nice one little Croco boy you're doing
great
you're doing great sweetie
oh physics
revive a medicine that can be used to
revive Pokemon just make it I'm all
right
she wants me to go this way probably
yeah so let's just explore
I wonder how the level system is
balanced for the fact that you can just
avoid encounters
it seems like it would be very easy for
somebody to not be super considerate
of the amount of wild Pokemon that they
need to fight in order to be able to do
the gyms
hello
the smallest thing I've ever seen
[Music]
I
think you should be mine
foreign
you want to come hang out
really cute
very cute
whenever you feel totally unequipped the
next Europe is that true she's like our
review saying that
I wasn't sure if that's
I figured it was electric which I always
like to have as my number two though I
do like a psychic type early on as well
uh the parents of exposure electricity
discharging organs
pour me fires electricity from its Four
Paws while standing unsteadily on its
hind legs
cute
poor me am I okay with poor me I don't
like that it sounds like I'm saying poor
me
no no I can stay it's too confusing
especially because like the only Pokemon
that I know very well are the first two
generations and then I really fall off
either because I skipped some games
um
or
I just didn't
make the effort to well I guess you
should fight with Paul me actually I
didn't make the effort to um
like really learn them super well
[Music]
you might die
I'll show you health
get a potion
the UI is great so far
oh you're gonna growl
that's okay I'm gonna swap you out
anyway
for pull me
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna take you right out of the sky
my guy my dude I really thought that
would have worked faster
but that's fine
Doug
great work so far for me
[Music]
give you a speech oh damn it I should
have stutter again
moments actually doesn't look as bad as
I thought it would I think same again I
do think the game is the frame rate is
not great and it's unfortunately just
very sharp
the resolution is a real bummer
um
but this isn't unplayable at all for me
so far
I imagine I will spend
I don't know what do I usually spend in
a Pokemon game like 80 hours or so
playing this I don't feel like I'm not
going to right now but
um
I imagine it probably gets worse that's
what's gonna happen
hey Alana are you getting the hang of
how to catch Pokemon okay
let me see so far you've caught
gaggio
oh that wasn't her I was like out of
character but okay writer sit uh game
freak whoa what was that
go
I don't need to do it the game's doing
it I've never heard that kind of crime
before it could be some strong Pokemon
or something
I say we find whatever made that cry
let's take a look around Alana just be
careful there's a kind of unsafe cave
not so far from here so steer clear
unsafe cave you said
[ __ ] I'll be right there
and I know your item phone can help keep
you safe but once you step by these
Cliffs anyway
got it
are you a Pokemon no just some flowers
[Music]
gonna get a lot of potions
move into the country gonna get a lot of
potions
potions come in a squirt bottle they
were put there by a man
in a Factory downtown
but if I had my little way
body potions every day
I don't know what the next line is I
know it sounds like
oh oh we already are seeing it
that happened so fast it's the one who
gave ice to the to the Tower
hello little friends for sure very tough
very scary so tough
actually pretty tough
what's the most randomly specific thing
about Australia that I miss Chicken Salt
Chicken Salt
yep
am I already gonna get this [ __ ]
vehicle Pokemon
shocking
Chicken Salt it's salt that's flavored
like artificial chicken chicken salt
chicken Salt just look it up chicken
Salt okay
I don't know how else to describe it all
out you get when you get your [ __ ]
chips from the fish and chip shop oh my
God I'm so excited to go home you just
get chicken salt on it no there is no
chicken Salt in the U.S nope
not that I've ever seen at least
exactly wrapped out you've got to get
the fish and chip shop chicken soft
it's chicken Salt Lake stock cubes for
better okay it's salt
okay it's salt you know how you have
chicken flavored chips
chicken flavored chips
right like literally crisps that are
chicken flavored and it doesn't taste
like chicken at all you know like
strawberry doesn't really taste like
strawberry chicken flavor doesn't really
taste like chicken
um Chicken Salt is just like if you made
salt
that tasted like chicken flavored chips
chicken salad
the mysterious Pokemon seems to be too
weak to move
maybe you can give it something to help
it perk up
hey
my guy can I interest you in an
adventure Guide would you like a phone
if they have pre-planned interactions
for that though that would be really
good
maybe I'll eat a sandwich
it's gonna need a potion it's gonna eat
the sandwich
this weak thing is just like bro please
dude I just need
you [ __ ] mum sandwich so bad
we didn't want to try the potion we
wanted to give it a lettuce and I don't
know ham whatever that is
it just needed a sandwich
the bike Pokemon
all it needed it was just hangry
this can't be happening
this I don't believe it
I remember when getting a legendary
Pokemon was a whole journey now it just
lays in front of you on the beach yeah I
mean I expected this to happen early-ish
because
we know the bike riding mechanicy thing
um but I didn't expect it to happen
this fast I was expecting maybe like
five hours in not immediately or maybe I
just see it here but I don't catch it
like that would be similar to
uh the Pokemon games
yeah he just gone back to that cave
for sure dude for sure
okay
all right
[Music]
all right
okay
[Music]
why'd he look at me with the side eye
all right you
Yoda ass
what the hell
foreign
it's not that hard to make a Shadow game
freak it's not that hard to just make a
Shadow
what did that sandwich have in it I
think my mom's lacing me with cocaine
oh he looked back at it okay are you
coming or like what like you know I mean
you don't have to follow me but just
like wondering are you or
no don't follow me oh my god oh no stop
following but are you gonna follow
though that's crazy
oh my God how do we end up in the in
like Grotto together that's like totally
unexpected oh my God I guess I've
decided that the legendary in this game
is a fairly girl
you add that to the voice cost oh my God
that's you know this is so cute that we
just like both happened to end up here
like I was going by myself like I would
have come even if you didn't follow me
that's crazy
oh she said oylana
I was like did the Pokemon just say that
there you are Alana you okay
you're not hurt right I'm fine
[Music]
thank goodness I was really worried she
got into her because I said we should go
looking for whatever whatever made that
cry
no never mind that right now we've got
to focus on getting you back up here you
just gotta find some way to climb out of
there if you can get close enough I'll
try pulling you up with one of my
Pokemon's moves
is she not
is she not seeing it I guess it's out of
her line of sight oh my God no like stop
I'm not even looking at you no it's like
I just am I'm looking actually out at
the beach I'm just like seeing if
anyone's following it's not even to do
with you
oh she saw it hey what's that Pokemon in
front of you kind of seems like it's
waiting for you does it want you to
follow it he thinks he's slick yeah yeah
it does
wait so that means we already get like a
rock smash move from the jump too guys
again maybe I'm not catching it right
now
[Music]
that Pokemon might be his strongest mine
okay love oh hello Houndoom hello my old
friend
I prefer to fight you
[Music]
okay well I didn't mean to do that
that's not what I intended to do can I
fight you
why did I mess that up
you just didn't I just I just threw him
out of the Pokeball but didn't really
aim
uh battle young goose
nice
I don't like that we collect their fur
when they die but that's it's fine it's
whatever
good work Bud oh my gosh you're so cute
oh it's a good point yeah do it oh
I take it back
foreign
I missed on purpose I did it I okay
all right to quit let's go
let's go little fella
let's do it
you trying to get slapped Diglett are
you trying to get slapped
you are
here under the high arrest texture just
load in my friend
how we wish it is it's just a bummer is
is what I would say about it it's just a
massive bummer that they are the way
that they are again
I'm enjoying playing this so far I'm
liking pretty much every aspect of it
it's just
Pokemon it's the highest grossing
franchise in existence
higher than Mickey Mouse
and dude this is very cool
um it is inexcusable
and I know that the switch is limiting
but how do you look so much worse than
other games on the switch
it's just a real shame
it's just Nostalgia pain for us I'm
enjoying the game I don't think it's a
kids thing
oh my gosh it's straight up pulverized
that rock I wonder what move that was oh
I want to see it up close I'm sure you
do I'm sure you do
a lot of look out something's coming
narrator Alana did not look out behind
you it's behind you
oh it's big boy
big boy came through
hey bud
he's a fan of metal helsinger for sure
this is the level 40.
um
isn't that just gonna take him out
immediately
[Music]
why are you so mad
[Music]
oh he returned it that's cool
get absolutely wrecked
[Music]
oh no puppies
pretty puppies oh what I'm gonna do with
it
that's why I'm still Star Trek after
meeting William zapka I loved William
Southco I mean Ralph machia was also
really really nice
um
but I was immediately rude to William
zabka like I made a joke that I like
you'd usually only make if you know
someone
um he apologized to me for something and
I was like you know who the [ __ ] do you
think you are
because that's who I am as a person and
he took it super well I think they were
both so lovely
Ralph came up to me because we filmed
the Kirby Kai stuff the day after my
birthday or a few days after my birthday
and he was like hey I heard it's your
birthday and I was like oh yeah
and he was like just wanted you to know
I'm thinking of you and I was like oh my
God thank you she's like paper box just
so sweet
way to go for a second I thought you
were both gone is
because of a level 40 Houndoom this is a
legendary Pokemon you stupid [ __ ]
also I feel like this could be teaching
kids bad messages it's like yeah maybe
we do Follow The Stranger if the
stranger looks like a bike
thank you Kindred Hunter
maybe it used up all its power you need
to know the focus term which
now it looks so different from a minute
ago you think it's okay
um well okay I would have said no but go
off I guess
you can't tell either Alana no it's it's
it needs a sandwich trust me [ __ ]
listen [ __ ]
this [ __ ] this guy needs a sandwich
well all that aside I'm seriously glad
to have you back here in one piece you
know that battle down there was really
something you and this fellow look
perfectly in sync facing down that
Houndoom
what you didn't even tell it what to do
I guess it's not like you're this
Pokemon's training yet huh
can this Pokemon just remain with free
will
I think it should
just have free will
I don't know that we need to catch it
can we just be Bros can we just be
homies
uh do you think this fellow is the one
making that mysterious cry we heard
before for sure yeah
I went ah
oh man oh man oh man the more I look at
this Pokemon the more mysterious it
seems
if you do become a trainer you gotta let
me battle against it
let's exchange numbers so we can get in
touch if we somehow get separated again
I'm also liking the pacing of this
tutorial I don't know there's things
that I'm enjoying about this game
that looks like ours
[Music]
and here this will let you teach your
Pokemon a move to help it battle against
stronger appointments nice tm3 Swift 32
sorry let me put tm032 Technical Machine
zero three two in your bags tm's pocket
Swift
think before you use it though TMS can
only be used once
I almost never use any of them
his turbo Graphics like this really okay
in 2022 no
no it again
not from Pokemon no
um
no it's not okay it's bad
that said I'm probably still going to
enjoy the game but I've also never been
a person who cares that much about
graphical Fidelity um but no it is bad I
mean it made me like kind of physically
ill so
um I'm also going to leave I'm recording
this for YouTube I'm Gonna Leave the
YouTube recording there so if you're
watching on YouTube everybody hi hey
thank you for watching please let me
know if you'd like or dislike seeing the
twitch chat I know some people find it
distracting but I feel like if I'm
streaming something and you can't see
the twitch chat it's probably very
confusing uh because then you don't know
what I'm responding to so
that's why I've been leaving it there
but if a lot of people just like feel
like it doesn't add anything then I'll
just get rid of it and that's totally
cool but yeah the second hour of this
plus more I'm sure I'll stream a bunch
of it over the next week because
Thanksgiving means we have a bunch of
time off we'll be on my thought Channel
my Twitter stream channel which I will
leave
in the description I'll see you guys
next time bye